paid search is an option meaning
advertisers place bids against the other
advertisers to show ads to consumers
that said the PBC auction system is
quirky and that the highest bidder does
not always win in this lesson I'll
reveal how the paid search auction
system works how bids are placed for ads
and how ads are ranked discover how the
paid search auctions can drive your
bidding and advertising strategy in the
world of paste in this video you will
learn to summarize the PPC auction
system label ad positions for a given
search engine results page understand
the importance of Quality Score
in determining a drink recognize how
tracking metrics and collecting data
related to your ads will allow you to
determine profitability before we look
at that though we should look at how
positions are determined these are items
you're going to see in your account of
the position of your ad so sometimes
you'll see ads at the top of the page
and then continue down the side other
times you'll just see ads on the side of
the page now ethers ad on the top and
the side of the page then position one
starts at the top and you'll see 1 2 & 3
then continue on the side of the page if
there's no ads on top of the page they
just start on this side they do this is
our still 1 2 3 and so forth google has
made some recent changes on the search
results with the side ads have been
removed
however some search partners do display
site ads so the way a drink is
calculated is not affected by the
changes in layouts as search engines are
often playing with various layout
formats the actual way ads are displayed
that you see in search results may
differ from what we display in these
videos but the overall information of
how a drink is calculated and what it
does for ad positions remains completely
irrelevant regardless of the layout of
ads on a search page
now when we look at these positions and
look at the average cost-per-click Oh
people are paying for a lot of people
just assumed you'd see a linear format
the number one position is the highest
CPC the second highest position is the
second highest CPC and so forth it's not
the reality of a lot of auctions what
you see in a reality is that position
one mate might pay 50 cents listen to is
paying 75 then 25 then $1 so CPC is
aren't linear due to how all the factors
go into place that affect how the
auction is run and the bidding process
works so the most important one to
really think about is known as quality
score the quality score at a conceptual
level is really just an opinion an
automated opinion of that of a search
engine that guesstimate how good of an
experience a search is going to have
with your ads and your landing pages so
as a search engine things going to have
a great experience you're going to have
a higher quality score it's going to be
a low experience it's a bad quality
score and so by classical gets put in
depth at a high level the most important
factors are things such as click-through
rate how often your ad is clicked on
essentially users voting by clicking on
your ad how relevant your ad is to your
landing page and your keywords this is
why that jour data group structure is
important because good structure make
sure your ads and your keywords are
highly related to each other increases
quality score and then landing pages all
your landing pages relate to this
information and so while quality score
is an automated opinion really by having
a good quality score following these
nuances of little organization good
landing pages these really does follow
best practices for how you structure
accounts to get better conversions from
them
Hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simply
learned Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here